you know what let's go with the d4
because i know some of you guys want me
to play d4
you want me to emphasize positional
concepts so i'm gonna you know i can
transpose into the modern but we're
gonna play c4 we're gonna forcefully
play the king's indian here so e4
this is the this will probably transpose
to the king's indian if he plays d6 and
knight f6
now a lot of people miss you know the
difference between the king's indian and
the perk
is um involves
white playing different moves so in the
perk white doesn't play the move c4 why
just plays e4 d4 and usually knight to
c3 and the king's indian
white adds this move c4 and
some of you guys might be like well why
would anyone play the
perk with white this just grabs more
space but as i've talked about many
times it's a meme now
getting more space in the opening isn't
necessarily a good thing yeah so we've
transposed into a king's indian
one of my favorite lines against the
kings indian the one that i recommend to
most of my students
is the sameish same issue named after i
think austrian grandmaster friedrich
samich
what move leads to the same issue
yes so i have three now never play f3 if
you've never seen this move before
i know it looks weird it's like what are
we doing here
um you know why are we taking away the
square from the knight
but there's more to it than that and
we first of all we build a little pawn
chain we defend the e4 pawn
and we create this little crevice right
and you
see this in many openings and we put the
bishop in that crevice
and then we're in most lines going to
castle long here and we are preparing
a kind of a sicilian style pawn attack
on the king side um and
there are lines where white can still
castle short here f3 is that such a huge
weakening of the king side um but
most of the time the same issue is one
of the is the only line against the
kings indian or white
regularly castles long so it's an
attempt to put the king's indian out of
commission now black of course has his
own attacking chances
okay so e5 by simon now the rule
for dealing with the center
when you've got um a kingside attack
going right do you want to open up the
center when you're attacking on a flank
or close it down what's the general rule
yeah so generally you want to close it
down so we go d5
we we don't have to rush with d5
actually but that's the more conceptual
move
yes and e5 is square of the old main
line
and our our plan here is going to be to
play so
we're going to play very straightforward
chess from like queen to d2 preparing to
castle long
and then we are going to begin the king
side attack h4h5 g4 you know
bishop h6 all these moves are very
standard in the king's indian and
if black is not experienced in this line
he can get checkmated super quick
because black has to know
how to manufacture attacking chances on
the queen side and that's not easy to do
because we've driven some pawns down his
gut here
and already simon is playing a little
bit too slowly this move rookie eight
is it it he's preparing to bishop hit
against bishop h6 but he has bigger
priorities he needs to start
getting stuff done on the queen side
how do we attack on the king said this
is an art
a lot of people just sort of close their
eyes and kind of
g45 slow down
and try to determine what the priorities
are now here's the thing
if we start by playing h4 black has a
way of
slowing down the king side attack in a
big way
how can black slow down in the attack if
we play h4 h4 is not a mistake but just
want to kind of alert you guys to some
of the subtleties here
yes black can play h5 and i know that
there is a rule which says you can't
push your pawns in front of your king
well
that's not always the case and the move
h5 gives black a lot of time because it
takes a while for white to play g4 and
break that now i can play g4
immediately and sack a bunch of puns
that gets super sharp i'll show you guys
after the game
so that's the drawback of playing it for
now what move can we play
in order to make h4 stronger and
i know a lot of you are thinking g4 but
it's not
what move other than g4 can we play what
non-pawn move can we play
yes so remember that one of the key
components of this attack is the move
bishop to h6
which is explained because we want to
get rid of his fiance bishop that is the
main defender of this king
and he can drop the bishop back to h8 i
assume that's why simon moved the rook
dude it's the typical idea
but the secondary purpose of bishop h6
is to pave the way to hold black down in
preparation for h4h5
a lot of people played g4 g4 is not a
bad move
but sometimes you can actually attack
without even playing g4
um and and that you can just play h4 h5
because
remember once again what is the point of
a pawn storm point of a pawn storm
is oftentimes just to open up files for
your rooks
right and it's not necessary and
sometimes you actually want to sacrifice
upon
you sometimes actually just want to give
this pawn up jettison it
so that this rook has an open h file
which it can attack on
so i'm not saying g4 is bad but
sometimes you can save time andrew if
black skillfully plays the queen side
every tempo is valuable here g4 we can
probably just get away with
yes if h4 h5 were already played i would
i would play so simon develops this
mission now
one very common mistake here is that
people take on g7 too early then yes you
know i got a chance to get that bishop
out of the way but remember
why you played bishop h6 yes trading the
bishops
is a good idea but it's more important
to prevent black from playing h5
does that make sense so if you take the
bishop and the play h4 you've kind of
um you've taken a step backward because
black can play h5 and also black can
move the rook into h8
if necessary bringing another defender
in so let's go h4
all right i mean i i think that makes
sense right
well sometimes we can sack the rook but
only if you have queen g5 as a
up here we don't necessarily have that
so let's see what simon does now we
don't have to rush with h5 we
and if we have time then g4 is a great
idea because g4
um makes sure that after h5 black can't
take on h5
um so simon he hasn't created
really any chances on the queen side for
now which basically means
that okay so now he's starting to do
something he wants to play b5
unfortunately for him i think he might
be a little bit too late
now here we need to weigh the pluses and
minuses
of playing h5 versus playing g4
so thank you i appreciate that so if we
play h5 it'll take with a knight
and then we can take the you know we can
try to go g4 to dislodge the knight
but if you calculate that this is where
calculation comes in aft
let's visualize h5 knight takes h5 g4
what very annoying square can that
knight access in that position
thank you fist of eden it's not just
going to obediently step back to f6
it's going to go to f4 very nice guys
and the reason that that is annoying is
because our queen
this the connection between white's
queen and the key h6 square which the
queen wants to access will be severed
and that's you know we can go to h2
there but then that loses more time so i
think here if we weigh the pros and cons
i think g4 is worth it i think it's
worth it to play g4 because
when we now play h5 black will not be
able to take with the knight then we're
going to open the h file on our own
terms then we're going to take the
bishop and slide our queen into h6
as you can see it takes a little bit
more time and that's time
simon can use uh to to attack on the
queen side but
as i've explained he's i think he's
delayed it long enough for us to
afford something like this well knight
g2 is slower right
knight g2 is possible yeah knight g2
would be another great way
to deal with this because it would cover
the f4 square with the knight but g4 is
more thematic it's sort of
the prescribed method of doing it and
the knight actually sometimes goes out
to h3 and g5 later so it's a little bit
more flexible
yeah pepper gin i'll explain why not
bishop takes any because that gives away
a key attacker
right if we don't miss the forest for
the trees here if you give up this
bishop
for a knight then it leaves them with an
uncontested dark-squared bishop
and white's attack kind of fizzles out
run
well and simon going king h-a which
which which is a good
defensive move i think he's trying to
slide the knife back to g8 or bring the
rook in
so he's sort of you know he's getting
into curling up into a ball and hoping
for the best
and i don't mean to talk about that
disparagingly it is a legitimate
legitimate defensive strategy but it's
it's
you know and it's hard to break down so
black's position is not as lost as you
guys may think it's attacking is not
when you know your opponent defends well
attacking is not a race it takes many
stages it takes time
to really break down the defenses okay
but this doesn't influence our strategy
we still want to go h5 and open up the h
file there's nothing else that we can do
let's go ahead and and do that rust dt
thank you for the gift
to buster boy yeah so
simon might be coming going rook g8 this
is a pretty decent defensive strategy
i don't think it's going to work in the
long term but it's going to stave off
checkmate
for quite a while that's for sure um
so when you're defending on a broad
level you often have to choose between
active defense and passive defense and
passive has a bad connotation but it
doesn't really shouldn't in chess
sometimes passive defense is what is
required sometimes you just do have to
curl
up into a ball because whatever counter
attack you may have is too slow and i
think this is the case here i like his
move
i think b5 would just it would be too
slow he would have to open up the b-felt
it would realistically take him five six
moves before he really created any
chances
if that makes sense um
so okay so again
our moves are pretty much autopilot
right now we want to open up the h file
nothing crazy there right we open up the
h file
now i'm assuming that he's going now g5
would be an instructive mistake because
remember that would allow his knight to
take on h5
so first order of business is to open up
that h file
meyer's nerd
don't tell the crowd about that
experience okay
fg now i'm gonna blow your guy's
mind i'm gonna make a move here that
people be like what so this whole time
right i've been talking about trading
bishops
but you have to be as i've talked about
many times very
receptive to the circumstance and the
way that they change you can't be
you can't tunnel vision anything got to
be ready to change the way that you
think about things
um and this is one of those cases now
this how has the circumstance
well this king is now a nature it's in
the direct line of fire of the rook
what does that mean where do we want our
queen ultimately we can have it on h6
what other square
could we move the queen to the same
intention yes
and you guys are all saying it beautiful
so we've dropped the bishop to g5
our plan is to go queen h2 and eliminate
the defender of the h fun
right so because he's driven his king
into a corner
now we actually want the bishop for a
different purpose than it was originally
intended for
we don't care about his bishop anymore
that's no longer the main defender the
main defender is now his knight
because it's protecting the h mono that
makes sense so we dropped the bishop
back
why don't we play queen h2 first because
then he can actually take our bishop and
that's actually bad for us
and bring his queen into f8 the queen
as i've discussed is often best in the
shadows on the
sort of in the back of the attack
because it's very vulnerable when it's
right in the king's face it can be
strong but it can also be susceptible to
attack when it's on h2
it's it's just as beastly as it is on h6
and it's
much less vulnerable
so before i thought about it but he has
got knight a4 that's actually a great
question and we should definitely look
at both sides of the board
uh but knight a4 does save the knight
and it would weaken our queen side
well queen e7 we have a beautiful move
there i hope he plays queen e7 then we
have a we have a gorgeous
gorgeous sac uh idea yeah bishop f8 i
mean all of these moves
stave off checkmate and you have to be
well moving knight to h5 would
remember that his knight is pinned to
the queen
you know if you're not finding checkmate
that
it's not because you did something wrong
you got to be very patient when you're
attacking as i've said before
if your opponent defends well you have
to accumulate the pieces and
you know as i said many times over
you know one stage of attack another one
keep nurturing stuff
so here for example what move should we
play
just to follow up on the previous move
yeah queen h2 if we take first that
would be too early because he would take
back
and then queen h2 would threaten
checkmate but it would easily but it
would just
it would be easily defended against and
then we would lose our bishop
yeah so simon kudos to him is defending
very very well given the circumstances
and i'm glad i'm getting a chance to
display okay so
this is a great time to practice
patience now there's no checkmate here
we can take the knight that would be a
horrible idea because we'd just be
giving up the bishop
and we need to find you know as i like
to say we need to add some tabasco sauce
to the attack what tabasco sauce means
is more pieces
now which pieces and to add more pieces
we'll need to be patient we can't bring
the knight to
h6 in one move now we can use
two different pieces come to mind we can
use a rook okay somebody proposed a
plan that involves activating the rook
and putting it on the right square
and this is not i don't think this is
what we're going to play
yeah rook to d2 then moving the queen
and then bringing the rook to h2 it's
not the ideal alkynes gun but it's the
best that we can do
do um so let me think about this for a
second
i actually have a really five head idea
but i'm not sure i actually am honestly
not sure if it's worth it
no it's not worth it
no that's too risky okay
so that's one idea that's what we're
going to do
we're going to go rook to d2 uh but then
maybe knight takes g4 is a nasty attack
so let's let's begin
let's begin by playing queen h4 and
increasing the the pressure on the
knight
and uh he's going to have to go bishop
to e7 here
and then we're going to go rook to
twitter i'll show you yep
just a boxing cage you deserve if you
were in the sub i would personally gift
you one
you you guessed that idea but there is
actually a problem
here guys and he is defending very well
now the bishop on g5
it's sort of indirectly attacked by two
pieces so
um what does anybody see what black is
threatening here kind of a
and i've talked about this idea before
the knight can move it can take on d5
and if we take the knight then he wins
our queen by taking the bishop
and if he takes the bishop then that
same night takes i show this to charlie
actually
so we actually need to defend the bishop
do we have a way to defend the bishop
without sort of moving it or doing
anything horribly and then h3
now i know some of you are thinking but
doesn't this block the h file right
isn't this counterproductive it does
but we're playing the long game here
we'll unblock the hval
it's fine that's just one more tempo and
black doesn't have anything going on the
queen side
um so this is a good example of being
patient and receptive to
the twists and turns of the attack um
and i actually miss knight takes d5 but
that doesn't mean we need to
we need to go crazy or lose our mind now
we're going to go rook d2 according to
plan
we're not distracted by a move like
bishop h6 which would open up
i know some of you were thinking that
but this would open up the x-ray against
the queen knight takes d5 would become
possible he might even stack an exchange
there
we're not looking for an exchange we're
ultimately going for a bigger prize
so we're playing methodically we're
slowly bringing all of the pieces into
the attack and we're
looking to break down his defenses
ultimately thank you gigahertz and
foucault
gifting to protected pawn and grubster
master and q key
cute k mind gift getting sub as well
thank you folks
thank you much okay so knight g8
if we break down this move this attacks
f3 it doesn't attack our bishop
in fact we wanted to take our bishop
because we'll capture with the knight
bring the knight into the attack [ __ ]
hurts another to
nasa lies and in fact speaking of knight
to g5
we have a very nice how should i call it
a restructuring of our pieces
what can we do what does that mean we
have a nice way to re
rejigger sort of our our attackers here
in order to include everything and
unblock the h file and you should always
look for this kind of stuff
yeah let's take the bishop and then we
play knight h5 knight g5
knight g5 you see what i'm saying stuff
like that you have to consider
um stuff like that you have to consider
capture and then
replace the night with the bishop thomas
wilson barnes another sub thank you for
the three months
yeah rejigger just means rearrange
okay knight g5 and are we threatening
anything guys are we threatening
anything
tacticalize
we are threatening checkmate when age
seven and rook h7 we might not even need
the third rook but we have it
in reserve if we need it
so step by step paint it long
but methodical we are breaking down his
defenses we might force the h pawn to
move that would create another weakness
yeah simon is defended and that's
another great move
now rook h2 here would be not that
effective because this is defended by
this knight as a hero
so what i'm thinking of and this is
where
i might not be very good at explaining
this but we have to look at both sides
of the board
and somebody earlier mentioned this move
b4
we're going to play this move now and
i'm going to show you guys why
this doesn't trap the knight as i
explained the night actually has only
one square
but this is leading up to something this
is leading up to something
and what this is leading up to well what
how does the position change as a result
of this trade what can we now do the
bishop is out of the way
what does this free up it frees up 96
right um it frees up 96 but after 96 we
have to reckon with queen takes f3
and yet i'm going to sacrifice that pawn
i'm going to sacrifice that pawn because
this is a
massive square for the knight i think
it's going to pay off
no i mean he had no choice that was the
only square for the night that he could
go to i'm still lilting
the southerner okay he decides to sack
the exchange that might be the best
thing that he can do
but now we have to be super careful so
i'm playing brilliantly here
because the queen wants to swing that's
the drawback of playing b4 we're
weakening our king so what move should
we make now we have to make a defensive
move ourselves
the rook is not hanging no no he said
king b2 is fine but what about bishop d3
getting the bishop out and
locking down the queen
locking down the queen rook d3 would be
a bit awkward and we have a chance to
develop our bishop here
well rook t3 wouldn't develop the bishop
and and it would violate the rule of
pieces of value right it would put a
lower value piece
um to in charge of something higher
value
piece in rather of something and he's
low on time here that's another
byproduct of
defending for this long right queen back
this rook we used to want to put it on
h2 but now we're going to put it on f2
so it can infiltrate to f7 flexibility
above everything and that will trap the
queen and win the game
so the attack concludes successfully it
was only 28 moves it looked like
50 moves it was so intense there's so
much happening
um but oh g5 that's a great defensive
move but
where should we put our queen
where should we put our queen
yeah we should slide it into h5 in order
to
prevent the queen from movies knight f6
is a great try but it's not going to
work
if we take the queen he takes we're
going to play queen takes h6 jack and
this wins rook h6 we're going to take
the knight
and this is going to be checkmate
forthcoming
yeah this is very nice
another pawn i mean this is i'm not
explaining this is easy we'll just take
everything
okay 200 bits thank you
yeah amazing game simon you uh
you're the man that was fantastic
defense i think you actually had chances
up until the very end
we'll wrap up after the explanation now
there's a lot i could talk about here i
don't want to over explain
now black's main move here is actually
c6
that's black's main move because what c6
aims to do and i used to play this line
this is the old main line
the bottom line here without oh you know
i don't want to talk too much about
theories that we
open up the queen side a little bit and
right we open up the c
file and we prepare b5 quickly so the
point is black very quickly starts his
own counter attack
and then you get a super sharp position
i've played a couple of games in this
line
white attacks on the king's side black
attacks on the queen side and it's
um it's just pandemonium so knight bd7
is a very king zindini move
that's why the same issue is good the
standard king's indian ideas often
aren't as effective in the sameish
because it's an unconventional way of
playing
so queen d2 preparing to castle rookie 8
and here i would still
maybe consider going c6 although here
you might be dropping that pawn
um so yeah knight bd7 is actually a
mistake
and here you started playing
phenomenally simon so bishop h6 right
um h4 allows h5 which is not
something that we want and now we go h4
we go g4 so once again if we go h5 here
and we take a lot of people like this
kind of concept and it would be
may if we could go queen g5 but we can't
because the queen defends that square
uh so and once again if we go g4 then
the knight slides into f4
some of you guys asked well what why
can't we just take but you're missing
the forest for the trees white's
why there's no attack anymore and the
bishop is uncontested right and
you know this is actually just very very
bad for white paddle bro thank you for
the three months
yeah so i would have played maybe be fun
b5 right away as a thought but
maybe something like this benko gambit
style but now white has b4
don't be afraid to push your pawns in
front of your king sometimes then i oh
and look at this position the knight is
just trapped
so the accuracies sure
i mean i think my accuracy might have
been lie i made something i made
quite a few inaccuracies probably there
in the attack
91.1 for me and 68 for simon but
obviously that's
it doesn't tell much of the story at all
in a game like this
you know the computer always finds
improvements attacking games often
feature a lot of inaccuracies but
this i don't you know that's why i don't
like checking the accuracy because it
it belies the actual the actual strength
right
okay so g4 um
and that's why we we prepare h5
can you explain the five head move yes
that'll be a little bit later looking at
jh5 now this i'm going through quickly
because
we are just doing what i said we would
do
and bishop to g5 right so we are now
yeah so could black have tried takes
takes and knight g
yes oh and then g5 to lock things down
that would have been a
pretty firefight defense that actually
would
oh that was actually a really
interesting defense
and things are locked up on the queen's
end now that doesn't mean white is worse
here
because now we can try to slide the
knight into f5 and stuff but that would
have been a really cool defensive idea
so you see you can be very creative when
you're defending some people like
defending for that reason but rook g8 is
understandable
okay so bishop to g5 preparing for h2
now we're threatening to take rook g7
this is a very nice idea simon
restructuring
and look at that just professional stuff
now
bishop h6 to kick the rook blocks the h
file and it opens up the x-ray so we'll
black and maybe well he can't take
because bishop takes his check but he
can move the rook
um so knight h3 to defend the bishop
okay so bishop h6 here there's knight
takes d5
um and and this this this leads to
complete
pandemonium he attacks the queen he's
going to ruin our pawn structure
so again when you are attacking you have
to be very
how should i put it you have to be very
discerning when it comes to
bailing out cashing out it's like you
won the lottery someone as you're
driving
you know someone flags you down and i've
made this analogy before it's like well
why don't you give me you know 100 bucks
i'll give you a hundred bucks right now
in cash right now here it is
but you just give me that little piece
of paper you got that little ticket ah
sure
now if someone offers you you know
million dollars in cash yeah maybe
you'll consider it but
um but but but that's kind of like
trading your attack in for winning a
rook versus trading your attacking for
winning an exchange
kim kim boga language right there so
rook d2
bringing in the rook re-shuffling
getting the knight involved we're
threatening queen takes h7
which would be checkmate and now
before attacking the knight now the the
five head move that i had in mind
guys the five-head move that i had in
mind was actually before
and after knight a4 we're trying to
build alakine's gun we're trying to get
this rook over to h3
um but i was a little bit worried about
this
first of all because it does weaken the
king and as i now realize i
it was a false alarm black has a really
cool tactical idea here who can tell me
what it is
what is 28 i think for the sub yeah
knight g4 is classic because the bishop
is hanging
and takes takes is fine for black but we
have queen h4
see this is this is even i miss these
kinds of moves
because the defense defends the bishop
and attacks a hard move to see
so probably we should have done this
then gone f4 and rook to h3
but i figured it's a little bit less
risky to just play more conventionally
now we go before opening up the e6
square for the knight
and actually simon i think after queen
f3 bishop d3
thank you foxtrot and the undone mariner
for the tier one love loving the sport
guys thank you
i think black is under tremendous strain
here but i actually don't see what the
follow-up is for white
like queen sack is not made i you know
white's position looks super impressive
but
i'm not sure black is worse here uh but
but the pressure is immense and and i
totally get
the impulse to you know to give up in
exchange but i just don't think you've
got enough here and this pawn is such a
strong pawn
and at this point i mean i think black
has just lost to get the rook and g5 was
a great move
but you just don't have enough here it's
just not enough uh not enough material
yeah you definitely i think would have
would have probably taken on f3 if you
had a little bit more time so
we'll play 15 minutes next time simon
that was a phenomenal defensive effort
that is how you defend you resist every
move
you bring pieces in you don't panic and
uh
you defend threat by thread but that is
a good i think illustration of the
common attacking ideas in the same ish
and uh you know this was a very very
hotly contested game it was like 28
moves but
it felt like so much longer 200 bits
from sbw thank you
take care everybody have a great weekend
and i'll see you guys tomorrow bye